wir wollen weiter über diesen digitalen
impfpass sprechen denn der war ja auch
thema beim eu gipfel
lasst uns einmal gemeinsam rein schauen
was die kanzlerin da gesagt hat
also die erwartungen schon dass bis zum
sommer zeitraum das fertig ist ich bin
keine technische programmiererin also
kann ich auch das nicht garantieren
genauso wenig wie ich impfstoffen
garantieren kann aber die politische
vorgabe ist dass man das in den nächsten
monaten erreicht habe von drei monaten
gesprochen
alle heute darauf hingewiesen dass das
zurzeit bei der geringen im durch
impfung der bevölkerung gar nicht das
thema ist aber man muss sich vorbereiten
und es geht auch nicht darum dass der
impfpass sozusagen das einzige ist man
kann es wurde darüber gesprochen dass
kinder zum beispiel ja noch gar keine
zulassung zum impfen haben das heißt es
kann so wie heute ein test verlangt
werden aber es kann ein impfpass auch
eine zusätzliche information sein und
ihn zu haben ist für die zukunft auf
jeden fall richtig das heißt aber nicht
dass nur reisen darf wer ein impfpass
hat darüber sind überhaupt noch keine
politischen entscheidungen getroffen ich
kann aber keine entscheidung treffen
wenn ich erst gar nicht entwickelt habe
also drei monate eventuelle war
politischer entscheidungen können noch
nicht getroffen werden also es scheint
nicht so jan als hätten wir jetzt beim
thema impfen den turbo eingelegt und
beim thema im pass schon gar nicht also
mit diesem ankündigung muss man ohnehin
vorsichtig sein gerade wenn es um
technische dinge geht das haben wir in
den letzten monaten wirklich gelernt
nicht nur auf bundesrepublikanischer
ebene sondern auch auf eu ebene von
daher würde mich das freuen wenn es
innerhalb von drei monaten klappt und
ich glaube uns alle würde es freuen aber
ob das dann so kommt das sei jetzt
einfach mal dahin gestellt wichtig war
den eu staats und regierungschefs das
vor beginn der sommerferien reisezeit
also dann natürlich doch irgendwie so im
juni/juli so ein impfpass zur verfügung
steht wie beeinflusst hat es denn wenn
man jetzt sieht dass unsere
nachbarländer so viel weiter sind da
geht es natürlich zum einen darum dass
wir alle aus dem block dort wollen aber
auch um wirtschaftliche dinge wenn es um
urlaub geht lässt sich die bundeskanzler
dass sich die regierung beeinflussen
wenn man hört in england ist im sommer
schluss mit lockt also es geht bei
diesem passt oder es gibt bei diesem
fast zwei lager muss man sagen es gibt
die die richtig voran gehen das sind
urlaubsländer wie griechenland wie
spanien die da sehr stark darauf
gedrängt haben dass es diesen impfpass
diesen elektronischen impfpass digitalen
impfpass gibt und der dann quasi auch so
etwas wie eine einreise berechtigung
darstellt die bundes
kanzlerin und immer nur makro haben da
ein bisschen stärker gebremst auf dem
gipfel
das hat man jetzt auch gerade noch mal
gemerkt und die bundeskanzlerin sagt ja
auch noch mal dass dieser impfpass aus
ihrer sicht jetzt zumindest in diesem
sommer noch kein reisedokument und
keinen freifahrtschein sein kann da
müsste es auch noch andere kriterien
gegen interessant ist nach jetzigen
stand kann sich natürlich alles wieder
ändern aber dass dieser im pass an jenem
ausgestellt werden soll digital also
aufs handy mutmaßlich die eine impfung
bekommen haben aber auch und das ist
dann die einschränkung muss man schauen
wie weit es dann geht wenn man einen
negativen pcr test beispielsweise
vorweist also dass man wenn man noch
nicht geimpft ist trotzdem kurz vor
beginn einer reise diesen test machen
kann und dann quasi auch so etwas
bekommt wie einen freifahrtschein die
aber nur natürlich vorläufig ist also
jan es scheint fast so als gäbe es also
zwei haken zum einen etwas digital ist
es hat gezeigt er auch in sachen app
wahn wir erst eine wunderbar
mittlerweile spricht keiner mehr drüber
also das scheint die erste hürde zu sein
und dann sagst du frankreich und
deutschland stehen da so ein bisschen
auf der bremse was er auch sicherlich
damit zu tun hat dass bei uns ja das
impfen noch nicht dementsprechend
forschung geht warum es uns einmal
gemeinsam schauen denn auch heute in der
pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister war der
digitale im fast thema wir sind leute im
vergabeverfahren dazu im dringlichkeit
vergabeverfahren dazu weil es ja auch
schnell gehen soll um es dann eben
innerhalb von plusminus bitte beachten
bis zu zwölf wochen dann auch verfügbar
zu machen
das sind natürlich sehr hohe
anforderungen einmal mehr an datenschutz
an sicherheit ein anderes zu beachten
andere frage ist und ich finde die
debatte muss wirklich im deutschen
bundestag soll jetzt auch als
abgeordneter und bürger breit geführt
werden ist ja die frage was folgt daraus
dass sich gm will folgt daraus was oder
nicht
und die diskussion findet der stadt und
sie muss auch stattfinden sie hat aber
meine aus meiner sicht nicht per se also
dass eine folgt nicht automatisch aus
dem anderen
das eine ist so oder so jetzt schon der
fall jeder in anspruch auf den nachweis
bis jetzt an hallo
im jahr 2020 soll es auch digital sein
das andere ist die frage folgt daraus
was und wenn ja was also wenn ja was und
zwölf wochen plus oder minus also da
wird ganz schön rum gesprochen deutet
sich da schon wieder das nächste
versagen an
also jetzt sparen ist natürlich jetzt
auch ein gebranntes kind und deswegen
glaube ich ist es ganz normal dass er
jetzt sich nicht mehr auf ein konkretes
datum festlegen will er hat es auch im
übrigen gar nicht in der hand sondern
wenn wir so etwas jetzt europäischer auf
die rampe schieben dann sprechen dann
natürlich wieder ganz ganz viele
möglicherweise regierungschefs oder
landesminister mit also ich bin gespannt
ob das sich wirklich in dieser kürze der
zeit auf den weg bringen lässt aber die
frage ist natürlich aus was für
möglichkeiten habe ich dann mit diesem
pass also wir haben das beispiel israel
ja auch noch mal genannt und gesehen ist
es dann möglich in restaurants zu gehen
wenn nicht geimpft bin ist es dann
möglich wieder ins theater zu gehen mit
maske oder ohne maske also kann man ein
bisschen so wie das leben wie vorher und
dass er das was ja entspannt eigentlich
angedeutet hat was er aber aus welchen
gründen auch immer das sind seine
eigenen gründe nicht ausgesprochen hat
möglicherweise wollte er die debatte
nicht wieder lostreten aber natürlich
ist diese debatte da die kanzlerin
bremst auch dort sie sagt es wäre
ungerecht wenn geimpfte jetzt wieder zu
ihren grundrechten komplett zurückkehren
könnten
denn es gibt einfach noch zu viele nicht
geimpfte diesen standpunkt kann man
teilen muss man nicht ich glaube es ist
eher so dass jemand der games eigentlich
sehr zügig die chance wieder haben
sollte zurück zu seinen grundrechten zu
kehren denn wir haben ja die grundrechte
ausgesetzt und nicht das gegenteil
gemacht sondern die grundrechte sind
beschnitten und jeder der bedingung
erfüllt also quasi geimpft ist der
sollte sie dann auch so schnell wie
möglich wieder zurückerhalten wenn es um
impfungen geht und vor allem dafür was
in zukunft für uns zu müssen wir auch
darüber sprechen einer der lichtblicke
ist der bayern-jackpot sahin wir konnten
jetzt exklusiv noch einmal mit ihm
sprechen bei bild und eine seiner
aussagen ist tatsächlich dass all das
hier ein licht am ende des tunnels wir
wollen zu seinem anschauen
er sagte nämlich im interview die
ergebnisse sind bisher viel besser als
ich erwartet habe
das licht am ende des tunnels wird
heller eine aussage die uns allen also
hoffnung machen kann und noch mal etwas
genauer auf die ergebnisse
die ja eigentlich meint dort hat er
jetzt davon gesprochen auch das wollen
wir uns einmal kurz anschauen
das jetzt erkennbar ist dass wir schon
bei den menschen die geimpft sind sehen
was die info mit ihm macht ein zentrales
ergebnis ist dass der impfschutz gegen
kuwait 19
nicht nur im labor und in kontrollierten
klinischen studien sondern auch im
realen leben wirksam messbar ist nämlich
zu 94 prozent und vergleichbar stark ist
in allen gruppen bei älteren und
jüngeren bei adipösen und
normalgewichtigen bei menschen mit und
ohne vorerkrankungen also alles dinge
die uns jetzt hoffnung machen vor allem
wenn wir dann hoffentlich bald alle
unsere impfungen bekommen wenn wir jetzt
über den sommer sprechen
gibt es da irgendwelche annahmen jetzt
schon da kann man jetzt fester sagen
wann denn in deutschland wirklich jeder
mit einer impfung rechnen kann wir
hatten das impfangebot bis ende des
sommers kann man sich darauf noch
verlassen weil jetzt ist ja mittlerweile
sind wir gebrannte kinder was das angeht
aussagen der regierung sehr gute frage
ich glaube wir müssen uns erst mal
darauf verlassen auf das was die
regierung sagt steht im wort die
bundeskanzlerin steht im wort der
bundesgesundheitsminister und die haben
das auch in den letzten tagen und wochen
immer wieder wiederholt dass es bis
spätestens ende des sommers am anfang
war es bis zum sommer mittlerweile ist
es bis spätestens ende des sommers also
bis mitte september quasi jeder ein
impfangebot bekommen soll
jetzt kann man nur hoffen dass das auch
so eintritt dass da haben jetzt keine
glaskugel um das sagen zu können aber
wir stellen fest dass das tempo der
impfungen nicht so richtig hoch läuft
wie man das eigentlich müsste wir impfen
zurzeit am tage entspannen hat sollte
morgen auch noch mal in der
pressekonferenz gesagt rund 160 personen
die bundeskanzlerin hatte vor wenigen
tagen gesagt wir müssen dahin kommen zu
bis zu neun millionen impfungen in der
woche wenn man jetzt die 160.000
hochrechnen auf sieben tage dann sind
aber derzeit bei knapp einer million
impfungen pro woche das ist weit
entfernt von den neun millionen die die
bundeskanzlerin anstrebt von daher
glaube ich musste mir da und patricia du
hast ja auch gesagt ganz schnell den
richtigen turbo einlegen ob das gelingt
entscheidet am ende darüber ob wir alle
ein impfangebot auch bis zum sommer
bekommen oder halt nicht wir hoffen
weiter darauf vielen dank gern dass sie
heute amt jagen
danke
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren